- [Instructor] Bond enthalpy
is the change in enthalpy
or delta H for breaking a particular bond
in one mole of a gaseous substance.
If we think about the
diatomic chlorine molecule,
so Cl2, down here is a
little picture of Cl2,
each of the green spheres
is a chlorine atom
and they're bonded together
by a single covalent bond.
It would take energy to break this bond
in diatomic chlorine gas
and turn diatomic chlorine gas, Cl2
in to two individual chlorine atoms.
So we're going from Cl2 in
the gaseous state to 2Cl.
Bond enthalpy can be
symbolized by the letters BE.
So the bond enthalpy of the
chlorine-chlorine single bond
is equal to +242 kilojoules per mole.
And what this means is,
if we have one mole of
chlorine-chlorine bonds,
it takes +242 kilojoules of
energy to break those bonds.
Bond enthalpies are always positive
because it takes energy to break bonds.
Another name for bond enthalpy
is bond dissociation energy.
So you might see this symbolized as BDE
or just simply the letter D.
Bond enthalpies are often found
in the appendices of chemistry textbooks.
For example, we just saw the
chlorine-chlorine single bond,
the bond enthalpy is
242 kilojoules per mole.
Whereas to break a
carbon-carbon single bond
takes 348 kilojoules of energy per mole
of carbon-carbon single bonds.
A carbon-carbon double
bond has a bond enthalpy
of 614 kilojoules per mole.
Since the carbon-carbon
double bond is stronger
than a carbon-carbon single bond,
it takes more energy to
break the double bond.
And that's why the
carbon-carbon double bond
has a high higher bond enthalpy.
So the higher the value
for the bond enthalpy,
the stronger the bond.
Notice that these are
average bond enthalpies.
So the average bond enthalpy
for a carbon-carbon single bond
is around 348 kilojoules per mole.
You might see slightly
different values for this,
depending on which
textbook you're looking in,
but they're all pretty
close to the same value.
The reason why these are
average bond enthalpies
is because if we look at two
different molecules down here,
this is ethane on the left
and propane on the right,
if we break a carbon-carbon
single bond in ethane,
the bond enthalpy is slightly different
from breaking a carbon-carbon
single bond in propane.
And that's why we use
average bond enthalpies.
We've already seen that it
takes energy to break bonds.
So to break the
chlorine-chlorine single bond
in diatomic chlorine gas takes
+242 kilojoules per mole.
If it takes energy to break bonds,
that means energy is
given off when bonds form.
So when two individual chlorine
gas atoms come together
to form a chlorine-chlorine bond,
so let's go into highlight that in here.
So this bond is forming,
energy is given off.
The magnitude of energy is
still 242 kilojoules per mole,
however, now we have this
negative sign in here
to indicate the energy is
given off when bonds form.
Bond enthalpies can be used to estimate
enthalpies of reactions.
So to find the change in the enthalpy
for a chemical reaction, you take the sum
of the bond enthalpies
of the bonds broken.
And from that you subtract the sum
of the bond enthalpies
of the bonds formed.
The minus sign is in there because energy
is given off when bonds form.
A good way to remember this equation
is to remember that B comes
before F in the alphabet.
So B before F therefore it's bonds broken
minus bonds formed.
Let's use bond enthalpies to estimate
the enthalpy of reaction for
the following reaction here,
methane with chlorine gas
to form chloro methane
and hydrogen chloride gas.
It's often helpful to draw dot structures
for these kinds of problems.
If we look at the methane dot structure,
we would need to break one
carbon-hydrogen single bond
in order to get to our products.
We would also need to break a
chlorine-chlorine single bond.
Next, one of the chlorine
goes over to the CH3
to form CH3Cl.
So therefore we are forming
one carbon-chlorine single bonds,
and the other Cl goes with the hydrogen.
So we also need to form one
hydrogen-chlorine single bond.
The next step is to
sum the bond enthalpies
of the bonds broken.
So let's think about this.
For our reactants we're breaking bonds.
So we have one mole of methane
reacting with one mole of chlorine.
And since we're breaking one
carbon-hydrogen single bond
for every one molecule of methane,
since we have one mole
of methane molecules,
we're breaking one mole of
carbon-hydrogen single bonds.
Therefore we can write down here,
one mole of carbon-hydrogen bonds,
and the bond enthalpy for a
carbon-hydrogen single bond
is 413 kilojoules per mole.
Since there's one
chlorine-chlorine single bond
for every Cl2 molecule,
and we have one mole
of chlorine molecules,
we're breaking one mole of
chlorine-chlorine single bonds.
So to this we're gonna add one mole
of chlorine-chlorine single bonds.
And the bond enthalpy for a
chlorine-chlorine single bond
is 242 kilojoules per mole.
Moles cancel out and we get that the sum
of the bond enthalpies of the bonds broken
is equal to 655 kilojoules.
Next, we need to sum the bond enthalpies
of the bonds formed.
So we're forming one
mole of chloro methane
and one mole of hydrogen chloride gas.
And since we're forming one
carbon-chlorine single bond
for every molecule of chloro methane,
since we're forming one
mole of chloral methane,
we're reforming one mole of
carbon-chlorine single bonds.
So let's write down here,
we're forming one mole
of carbon-chlorine bonds
and the bond enthalpy
for a carbon-chlorine single bond
is equal to 328 kilojoules per mole.
And since we form one
hydrogen-chlorine single bond
for every molecule of hydrogen chloride,
since we're making one
mole of hydrogen chloride,
we're forming one mole of
hydrogen-chlorine single bonds.
So to this we add one mole
of hydrogen-chlorine single
bonds and the bond enthalpy
for a hydrogen-chlorine single bond
is 431 kilojoules per mole.
Moles cancel and we get that
the sum of the bond enthalpies
of the bonds formed is
equal to 759 kilojoules.
Next, we're ready to find
the change in enthalpy
for our chemical reaction.
The sum of the enthalpy
of the bonds broken,
we found that was equal to 655 kilojoules.
And from that we subtract the
sum of the bond enthalpies
of the bonds formed, which
we found was 759 kilojoules.
So 655 minus 759 gives -104 kilojoules.
Sometimes we see kilojoules
or kilojoules per mole
or kilojoules per mole of reaction.
Kilojoules per mole of reaction just means
how the balanced equation is written.
And let's see how we can look at the units
to get kilojoules per mole of reaction
when we do the calculations.
If you go back to breaking
the carbon hydrogen bond over here,
we've seen there's one mole
of carbon-hydrogen bonds
that we need to break for
how the equation is written.
Therefore, we can write
a conversion factor
of one mole of carbon-hydrogen bonds
per one mole of reaction as it's written.
And then we multiply
that by the bond enthalpy
as 413 kilojoules per mole
for a carbon-hydrogen bond,
this cancels out moles
of carbon-hydrogen bonds
and this gives us kilojoules
per mole of reaction
as our units.
So it's more time consuming
to write it this way
but we could do that for all
of our different bond enthalpies
to get kilojoules per mole of reaction
for the units for our final answer.
When everything is under
standard conditions,
we need to add a superscript of note.
So this would be the
standard change in enthalpy
for a chemical reaction.
So for the value we just calculated,
- 140 kilojoules per mole of reaction,
this is under standard of conditions.
So this is actually the
standard change in enthalpy
for this chemical reaction.
Remember that bond
enthalpies are only averages.
And so this value that we
calculated is only an estimate
for the standard change in enthalpy
for this chemical reaction.
A more accurate way of
finding this standard change
in enthalpy for a chemical reaction
is to use standard
enthalpies of formation.
And when you use standard
enthalpies of formation
to find the standard change in enthalpy
for this particular chemical reaction,
you get -99.8 kilojoules
per mole of reaction.
So -104 is pretty close to -99.8.